Okay,
you know,
it's like,
um,
we're living in the,
in the first days of,
of mass self organization.
Um,
you know,
clay shirky likes to say this is as big
a change is the admission of the
printing press was 500 years ago.
We now have ridiculously easy tools for
organizing ourselves.
And so the political impact is huge.
The,
the,
the presidential election just is like a
huge training ground.
So there were thousands of thousands of
people who have just gone through an
experience of effectively discovering
how good they can be as organizers,
right?
They've learned how to a survey,
their own local political landscape and
figure out how to deliver the votes that
were needed for the larger cause.
In this case of electing Obama,
many of these people aren't going to,
they're not going back to what they were
before this,
you know,
the Obama campaign surveyed a,
their supporters after the election,
they got about half a million actually
filled out a detailed survey and 10
percent,
50,000 people said they're interested in
running for office,
which means a whole new wave of,
of energy entering the political process
at every level.
And whenever that happens,
um,
you're,
you're bound to have a change in as well
in what the incumbents do and as these
people get elected and then rise and,
you know,
start running for higher office,
it has a larger societal effect.
So I think,
you know,
you might call this the Obamas coattails
and he is just the beginning of that
much bigger wave that's going to spread
through American society.
Assuming that we don't have a political
disaster.
I mean,
I'm assuming he,
he lives up to the promises that.